Please welcome, Kumail Nanjiani,
Olivia Munn, Dave Franco,
Zach Woods, Abbi Jacobson, Michael Pena,
and Justin Theroux!
(audience applause and theatrical music)
[Conan] Have a seat, please!
(audience applause)
You can have whatever you want.
Please, everybody, please for God's sake.
[Kumail] Oh my God!
(audience cheering)
Nice seating by the way.
(laughing)
My chair is, I can't get
it to stay the right ...
[Andy] These stools are designed
to make you feel
uncomfortable and insecure.
(laughing)
[Zach] I feel like I have an inert--
[Kumail] Have I been sitting
on these stools my whole life?
(laughing)
Alright well let's start with you, Kumail,
because you made it all
about you instantly.
(laughing)
You've been to Comic-Con many times,
what's your advice for
newbies at Comic-Con?
I would say, you know,
you gotta bring your A-game.
You gotta have Purell.
I carry Purell with me.
Drink Purell, shower in Purell.
And also the other thing
not many people know
everyone in a mask is a celebrity, so.
Just go up to them and
be like, whisper like,
"I know who you are."
And then get them to sign
your Ninja Turtle lunch box.
(audience laughs)
Yeah. Now what about,
what else you noticing about Comic-Con?
You've been an old hand at this.
What have you--
Oh, you guys know what stink shoulder is?
This is what stink shoulder is!
Okay, I was talking ...
So you know, a lot of attractive women
will dress up as characters
and then dudes will be like,
"Can I get a picture with you?"
And what they'll do is
they'll put their arm
around the lady, and their
armpit is in the girl's shoulder.
(audience laughs)
And so their shoulder starts stinking.
It's called stink
shoulder, so these ladies,
you'll see them, they'll be
like Purelling their shoulder.
(audience laughs)
Now okay, Oliva, let's find
out if this is true or not.
You've been to Comic-Con before
you were dressed very nicely,
you had a lot of dudes
putting their arm around you.
Did you experience that?
Yeah, I have been a
victim of stink shoulder.
(audience laughs)
It's something I--
There you go.
(audience laughs)
Let me.
(audience laughs and cheers)
I know, I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
[Zach] Now you have predator shoulder.
(audience laughing)
Say that again?
[Zach] Now you have predator shoulder.
(laughing)
You guys, it just looks
like somebody just,
you know, on my shoulder.
(audience laughs)
[Kumail] That's a real stink shoulder.
(laughing)
[Conan] The invisible man.
(audience laughs)
The invisible man's been at it again!